hoy se otorgó el premio Nobel de
economía
Por investigar los bancos y las crisis
financieras los premiados o mejoran
significativamente mejorar O mejor dicho
significativamente la comprensión del
papel de los bancos en la economía
particularmente durante la crisis lo que
ha ayudado a regular los mercados
financieros nos acompañan por supuesto
nuestra cronista de economía Daniela
Blandón Daniela Qué bueno tenerla en
esta sección de invitado del día del día
de hoy cuando se entregó el Nobel de
economía Hola Raúl Muchas gracias fue
así viendo este Nobel de economía que
tiene tengo muchas preguntas
personalmente para nuestra invitada
porque promete ser bien polémico y que
se las vamos a hacer Oriana monti y
economista candidata a doctora en la
economía Internacional de la British
University en Estados Unidos
especializada en temas de política
comercial entre China y Estados Unidos y
en desarrollo económico de América
Latina Oriana Gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo América de Francia
24 muy buena mañana de lunes
Hola cómo están Buenos días Buenos días
Soriana pues comienzo yo porque el
premio Lo otorgan por las
investigaciones de estas tres personas
que ayudan a saber o a Mejor dicho que
dicen como los bancos a entender cómo
los bancos han servido de apoyo para
evitar crisis financieras y cómo los han
rescatado para evitar crisis peores de
las que se avecinan Qué opina usted de
de esta razón por la que les dan el
Nobel a estos tres economistas
bueno la declaración de hoy digamos el
comunicado de prensa del premio refiere
al rol de estos investigadores en
analizar el rol de los bancos y de las
crisis financieras en particular Cuál es
el rol que tienen estos bancos en hacer
las crisis más o menos profundas
Oriana le queríamos preguntar digamos el
rol de los bancos en un contexto actual
no que hemos evidentemente una subida de
las altas desde una subida en las tasas
de interés de los bancos centrales
estamos digamos a punto de entrar
digamos según varios economistas en
varios organismos internacionales en una
recesión económica la importancia de que
ellos hayan entendido estas crisis
financieras pasadas No para lo que
podemos enfrentar en un futuro en la
actualidad mejor dicho
Bueno en realidad la situación actual es
diferente en el sentido de que no se
trata de una crisis financiera como fue
por ejemplo en el 2008 o como fue la que
estudia bernarque en los años 30 en la
gran depresión lo que hacen estos
autores por ejemplo un modelo muy
importante de Diamond es respecto a las
corridas bancarias que muchos nosotros
en América Latina conocemos lo que son y
cómo el desparramar un rumor respecto a
que un banco puede no llegar a tener
suficiente dinero puede generar una
crisis incluso Aunque el banco sí lo
tuviera en su momento porque mucha gente
va a la misma vez muchos depositantes
van a la misma vez al banco a pedir sus
depósitos y el banco no tiene lo
suficiente capacidad para responder Este
es el principal aporte de diamantine Big
bernalky como les decía el estudio lo
que pasó en la crisis de los años 30 y
como los bancos
la que quiebra sostenida de los bancos
hizo que esta crisis fuera aún más
profunda la situación actual diferente
en el sentido que no no estamos viviendo
una crisis bancaria sino que es
la situación macroeconómica es más
importante hoy en día digamos es la
inflación
Oriana yo siento que puede haber algo de
polémica porque ellos resaltan el papel
de los bancos en la economía y cómo
sirve rescatarlos en determinados
momentos pero yo recuerdo cuando en 2008
hubo esta crisis y que la mayoría de
gobiernos salió a rescatar los bancos
fueron muy criticados porque se estaban
usando recursos públicos para salvar a
banqueros entre comillas y responsables
un ejemplo por ejemplo de Islandia que
Islandia no salvó a los bancos y salvo a
la gente y terminó con una economía pues
más brillante que muchos pares en Europa
y terminó criminalizándolos a ellos
Entonces cómo puede también esto ser
algo polémico debido a ese papel también
de los bancos en la economía bueno así
sin duda lo que pasó en el 2008 en
Estados Unidos que generaba una crisis
financiera global tuvo mucho que ver con
comportamientos
poco prudentes de parte de los bancarios
y en algunos casos incluso delitos y eso
fue todo procesado en su momento y
también generó un cambio en La
regulación de parte de la reserva
Federal este
uno de los galardonados hoy fue
presidente de la reserva Federal del
2008 Janet y el en que es la actual
secretaria del tesoro en Estados Unidos
también fue posterior y hicieron este
esas modificaciones sin duda rescatar
bancos tiene connotaciones políticas
complicadas en particular las
recomendaciones de política que por
ejemplo el modelo de Diamond plantea
tienen que ver con si el gobierno
prestamista en última instancia y
también seguros de depósito eso también
tiene que ver con las de digamos qué es
lo que la sociedad elige y como ustedes
planteaba las demandas de la sociedad y
como eso se canalizan en el sistema
político
pero creo que lo que vale rescatar Hoy
es el rol de los bancos y que las
personas en general entendamos un poco
mejor cómo es que funcionan y cómo
cuándo pueden catalizar una crisis y
cuando se puede eso controlar
Oriana y también quería hacer énfasis en
el Nobel como tal la mayoría de Nobel de
economía han sido entregados a personas
de Estados Unidos y solamente dos
mujeres lo han ganado en toda la
historia qué opina también de esto bueno
sin duda muestra que la economía en
general es un campo muy masculinizado
de hecho la segunda ganadora fue hace un
par de años este ardus lo que es una
economista francesa y la primera
ganadora que fue oslón de apellido ni
siquiera tuvo un doctorado en economía
porque no la aceptaron en su momento la
economía sino que hizo un doctorado en
sociología y luego continuó sus estudios
y es cierto que actualmente los tres
galardonados este Residen en Estados
Unidos son estadounidenses y trabajan en
universidades de acá es cierto que la
economía como como campo académico y de
práctica necesita todavía trabajar mucho
para diversificar las visiones tanto
geográficas como
rápidamente Oriana antes de despedirla
yo quería preguntar sobre eso no la
importancia de las crisis económicas que
hemos vivido en la humanidad que le han
permitido a estos galarrunados pues
estudiarlas para estar mejor preparados
en un futuro y también quería
preguntarle sin actualidad digamos la
sociedad y sobre todo los economistas y
los grandes bancos del mundo y los
bancos centrales del mundo están
preparados para una nueva crisis
económica
bueno como les decía la crisis actual es
diferente en el sentido de que no es una
crisis financiera sino que surge bueno
por la pandemia las medidas este
económicas de los países en particular
por ejemplo Estados Unidos para
recuperar la pandemia las crisis por
supuesto la invasión de Rusia a Ucrania
y las crisis de las cadenas globales de
valor creo que lo que sí ha pasado a
partir del 2008 es que se aumentó La
regulación como les decía se aumentó los
controles en los comportamientos de las
personas que toman las decisiones los
comportamientos criminales y en La
regulación de los de los bancos en
general en general en estos sentidos La
regulación siempre viene detrás como que
se inventan cosas nuevas y después se
viene a regular
pero pienso que este tipo de información
puede de este tipo de investigación
informa las prácticas de la política
económica de contribuyen a una mayor
estabilidad